now chris there's a lot to catch up on
here because i
you said something the last time we
spoke that stuck with me now i talk to a
lot of people
and i talk to them and the minute i'm
done talking to them i immediately
forget what they said but you said
something that stuck with me which is
that you had started going on
cameo cameo of course the service
where a celebrity can go on and give a
quick message to somebody and make
uh usually like a smaller amount of
money but
but you've been doing that and
that stuck with me because i thought i
haven't talked to anybody
who's doing cameos so i i want to sort
of catch up on that how's it going are
you still doing or did you
abandon cameo i thought long and i i
i want to abandon cameo i find it to be
weird
but it's also a nice way to make small
amounts of money
now that i can't tour and go on the road
so i i do it if you remember
last time specifically there was this
one guy named randy yes randy yeah
yeah he had caught covid and then i was
making a lot of money
because his friends were buying cameos
from me to wish him well
tell him to get better and you
accurately pointed out that maybe that's
not
cool to monetarily exploit a sick man
yes
conan since then since my last
appearance this guy's become a
cash cow he got electrocuted i made a
lot of money when that happened wait
wait a minute so he got better he got
better from kovid he recovered from
covid
but then got electrocuted yeah i was
sitting there like man this
i guess this well is dried up and then
no he uh he touched a loose wire
in the back of a u-haul truck and
electrocuted his hands
he burned his hands i got i got coined
for that
then he moved to northern michigan and i
guess when he hit the cold his hands
were having all these pains he found out
that he had
broken bones from when he was a teenager
and they hadn't healed right so he has
to get surgery on his hands
cha-ching and then
i just saw on instagram i followed the
guy on instagram the other day this i
thought was just truly insane randy if
you're watching
i am serious he put a post on instagram
conan he bought a boat it's a picture of
him standing in front of a boat i'm like
randy
with your luck take that boat and push
it into the ocean with your broken burnt
hands and never
think about it again man like you're bad
luck
johnny to the court don't get on a boat
and i
stand to financially gain a lot if he
has a boating accident yes i don't
that's a lot of money anymore
i don't want any more of randy's paying
money i don't want any more well
wait a minute of course you say you
don't want it but you're not turning it
down
and you've referred to him several times
you you
describe one of his horrible injuries
and then you start
laughing and you call him a cash cow
so don't tell me that you oh i can't
take any more of his money
look if we're living in the awful stages
of late-game capitalism
right and if uh the guy who owns amazon
can make 13 billion dollars in a day
then i can make 35 dollars when this guy
randy electrocutes his hands is that the
amount of money that you get
uh when you're on cameo is it 30 is is
that what you get 35
a pop they take a cut so i get like 28
and i've been on tv a bunch of times i'm
getting 28 dollars a pop on these weird
videos of my
awful pale head uh my um
my wife has all these friends back from
she's from seattle and she has these
friends
that are very sharp uh they're witty and
they're sharp
and we were hanging around in seattle
before covid this is like a little over
a year ago
and we were having uh drinks uh
and someone was talking about cameo
and how they got like the kid from
different strokes to wish him a happy
birthday
and uh they said how much money it was
and i said
do you think when do you think's the
time for me to go on cameo
and one of her friends looked at me and
he said three years ago
wow nailed it nailed it
i think he's actually six years ago